hace algunos vídeos atrás nosotros
introducimos la idea de longitud de un
vector y esto era una idea genial porque
estamos acostumbrados a la longitud de
cosas en dos o tres dimensiones pero se
vuelve bastante abstracto cuando
nosotros llegamos a n dimensiones si por
ejemplo tenemos un vector de 100
componentes por lo menos para mí es
bastante difícil visualizar el vector en
100 dimensiones pero en realidad hemos
definido su noción de longitud y
nosotros vimos que esto en verdad es un
valor escalar es sólo un número en este
vídeo quiero intentar definir la noción
de ángulo entre vectores como se puede
ver estamos construyendo esta matemática
de los vectores desde la base y no
podemos decir simplemente yo sé que es
un ángulo porque pues todos sabemos lo
que es un ángulo o incluso longitudes si
solo lo aplicamos a vectores de dos o
tres dimensiones es decir a un espacio
vip o tridimensional pero en todo el
estudio del álgebra lineal consiste en
extraer estas ideas a un espacio
multidimensional y bueno ni siquiera ha
definido todavía lo que es una dimensión
pero creo que ya tiene una idea hasta
cierto grado de lo que esto eso creo que
tenemos una buena idea de qué es
una dos o tres dimensiones y bueno a
continuación lo primero que voy a hacer
es tomarme dos vectores que existan en
rn que existen en rn y que están
vectores que no son cero así que vamos a
escribirlo me voy a tomar dos vectores
mi vector am y mi vector b
tales que existan en rn es decir pueden
existir en un espacio con n dimensiones
pero lo que voy a pedir es que ni a ni b
sean el vector 0 así que bueno para
hacer esto un poco más didáctico voy a
suponer que están en r 2 o que al menos
podemos visualizar a estos dos vectores
por lo tanto voy a dibujar aquí el
vector am y esto de aquí va a ser mi
vector ven ojo estamos visualizando
estos dos vectores y bueno este vector
que tengo aquí si pensamos en colas y
cabezas es a menos vemos y lo podemos
revisar porque es el vector al cual si
nosotros le agregamos b me da el vector
a
es decir el vector de más el vector a
menos bm da el vector am y creo que aquí
lo podemos ver con mucha claridad ahora
bien lo que voy a hacer es construir un
triángulo muy parecido a este triángulo
de vectores que tengo aquí pero
este triángulo va a tener en lugar de
vectores medidas y es que recuerda que
estos vectores no forzosamente tienen
que estar en r2 pueden ser bestias que
estén en en las dimensiones lo único que
estoy tomando es una visualización de
ellos cada uno de ellos podría tener no
sé por ejemplo 100 componentes pero para
ayudarme a tomarme la definición de
ángulo entre vectores lo que voy a hacer
es un triángulo muy parecido a este
tenemos lo que tenía aquí pero con una
gran diferencia en lugar de estar
construido por vectores lo voy a
construir con la longitud de estos
vectores es decir con una medida escalar
aquí no voy a tomar la longitud de amd
aquí no voy a tomar la longitud de a
menos ven a menos ve a menos ven o menos
a perdón y aquí también voy a tomar la
longitud de ve y date cuenta que como
las longitudes son números escalares son
números entonces puedo construir este
triángulo y es que este triángulo me va
a servir bastante para que yo pueda
definir lo que es un ángulo entre
vectores pues este triángulo hasta lo
puedo dibujar en un papel y bueno lo que
sería muy importante saber es qué
condiciones necesito
para que este triángulo system es decir
qué condiciones son necesarias para que
yo pueda construir este triángulo dados
mis tres vectores y bueno se me ocurre
que para responder a esta pregunta puedo
pensar en la pregunta contrario las
razones para las cuales no se podría
construir no se podría construir este
triángulo que tengo aquí y bueno se me
ocurre que no se puede construir un
triángulo si alguno de los lados es
mayor que la suma de los otros dos es
decir supongamos que me tomo el lado
cuya longitud es la longitud de ver si
la longitud de b es más grande que la
longitud de a más la longitud de a menos
b entonces este trago no no se podría
construir te imaginas un triángulo que
tenga un lado enorme y el otro otros dos
chiquitos no se podría construir un
triángulo al cual le pasará esto si uno
de los lados es mucho más grande que la
suma de los otros dos pues entonces no
puedo construir un triángulo y bueno
esto también pasa si me tomo cualquiera
de los lados y de hecho creo que sería
bastante bueno juntarlo si yo me tomo
que uno de los lados es la longitud de b
y que ésta sea mayor que la longitud de
a más la longitud de a menos b pues
podría pasar lo mismo 100
lado en el que me estoy fijando es el
lado que tiene la longitud de a el lado
cuya longitud es la longitud de afuera
más grande que la suma de las otras dos
longitudes es decir la longitud de a
menos ver más la longitud de b si pasara
esto no se podría formar un triángulo y
de igual manera si nosotros nos sumamos
la longitud de menos b y esto es más
grande que la longitud de up más la
longitud de b tampoco podríamos
construir un triángulo con estas
dimensiones con estas longitudes
recuerda que si pasa alguna de estas
tres desigualdades nos estamos
refiriendo un triángulo con un lado
enorme y los otros dos lados muy
pequeños es decir un triángulo que no se
puede construir y bueno cómo podemos
asegurar que no va a pasar esto si yo me
tomo vectores en r 100 o en r 1000 y
bueno para demostrar que no pasa esto no
voy a tomar la desigualdad del triángulo
la famosa desigualdad del triángulo así
que vamos a recordar que decía la
desigualdad del triángulo me decía si yo
tomo la suma de dos vectores y me tomo
la longitud de esta suma de dos vectores
esto siempre es menor o igual que la
longitud del primer vector
la longitud del segundo vector y esta
desigualdad del triángulo le aprobamos
hace algunos vídeos es bastante útil y
ahorita nos va a resolver este problema
porque fíjate bien así yo me tomo por
ejemplo la longitud de a y vamos a ver
si la longitud de a puede ser que sea
más grande que la longitud de a menos
vemos la longitud de b pero bueno aquí
lo importante es que te fijes que el
vector a lo podemos ver como el vector
de más el vector a menos vedad de cuenta
que estos dos son exactamente lo mismo
el vector es lo mismo que tomarme el
vector b ya esto sumarle el vector a
menos b hasta donde hemos definido
operaciones con vectores la suma de
estos dos vectores me darían el vector
así juntamos cola con cabezas y bueno
entonces si yo lo separa ahora con los
paréntesis y utilizo en la desigualdad
del triángulo me queda que esto es menor
o igual que tomarme la longitud de ven
fíjate la desigualdad del triángulo me
estoy tomando la longitud de b más la
longitud del vector a menos ven y
perfecto porque esto es justo lo
contrario lo que tenemos aquí arriba me
acabamos de dar cuenta que la longitud
del vector a 100
es menor o igual que la longitud del
vector b más la longitud del vector a
menos b y por lo tanto esto no puede
pasar por eso lo estoy tachando porque
esto nunca va a pasar y me encantan las
matemáticas porque me refiero al siempre
de los siempre es ahora vamos a ver si
es posible que pasa que la longitud de b
sea más grande que la longitud de a más
la longitud de a menos b y para esto voy
a utilizar la misma trampa no voy a
fijar en b y lo voy a construir de la
siguiente manera como el vector a ya
este vector de voy a sumar otro vector
pero date cuenta que no va a ser el
vector a menos b porque el vector a
menos b tiene la dirección contraria
entonces me voy a tomar el vector que
vaya en la dirección que me es favorable
para esta construcción y es el vector a
menos b negativo es decir el vector de
menos a recuerda que para cambiarle la
dirección a un vector lo único que hacía
era multiplicarlo por menos 1 y bueno ya
con esto podemos usar la desigualdad del
triángulo otra vez y esto me va a quedar
menor o igual a la longitud del vector a
más la longitud del vector de menos a y
en este momento es cuando más a decir
jajaja pero es que estas dos cosas no
son iguales yo lo que quiero ver es que
él
o sea mayor que el vector a más el
vector
b sin embargo lo que quiero que te des
cuenta es que el vector de menos a y el
vector a menos b tienen la misma
longitud fíjate bien si me toma el
vector de menos a esto es lo mismo que
menos 1 por el vector a menos b recuerda
que para cambiarle la orientación de un
vector lo único que había que hacer era
multiplicarlo por menos 1 y si ahora me
tomo la longitud de ambos lados de esta
igualdad qué creés me va a quedar que la
longitud de menos a es igual a menos 1
por la longitud del vector a menos b que
si hablamos de longitud es la longitud
del vector a menos b es lo mismo que la
longitud del vector
b - y hasta sería un buen ejercicio que
tú probarás esto el cambio de
orientación no cambia la longitud que te
des cuenta que dos vectores el cual uno
lo podemos ver como menos una vez el
otro tienen la misma longitud lo único
que cambia es el sentido y por lo tanto
ya puedo cancelar esta otra desigualdad
porque la longitud debe menos a es
exactamente la misma que la longitud de
a menos b y entonces esta desigualdad se
me va y solamente me falta probar el
caso de la longitud de a menos b ahora
lo que quiero que veas es que el vector
am
lo podemos escribir la siguiente manera
como el vector a más el vector menos b
es decir lo que voy a hacer es cambiarle
de dirección a b y en lugar de ir para
acá ahora va a ir en sentido contrario y
entonces si nosotros empezamos en el
rector menos b y le sumamos a entonces
nos da el vector a menos ven y bueno
esto me da pie a que pueda utilizar la
desigualdad del triángulo la cual nos va
a dar justo lo que queremos además
recuerda una cosa que acabamos de ver
que es muy importante la longitud del
vector b es exactamente la misma que la
longitud del vector menos 20 y por lo
tanto si aplicamos la desigualdad del
triángulo me queda que la longitud del
vector a menos b es menor o igual que la
longitud de a más la longitud del vector
b porque estas dos longitudes son
iguales la longitud del vector menos b y
la longitud del vector b y perfecto con
esto también podemos quitar el tercer
caso que teníamos de las razones para
las cuales no podíamos construir este
triángulo que necesitábamos
es decir fíjate lo importante que te
estoy diciendo si yo me tomo dos
vectores en rn dos sectores que no sean
cero entonces yo puedo construir siempre
un triángulo con estos dos
y nunca me va a quedar un triángulo de
forma con un lado más grande que otro y
es más vamos a volver a ponerlo aquí
porque el triángulo que me voy a tomar
es un triángulo muy importante si yo
aquí me tomo el vector am y aquí me tomo
el vector de este de aquí es mi vector a
menos de este que va de aquí acá es mi
vector a menos b y bueno lo que yo hacía
era fijarme en la longitud de a en la
longitud de b y en la longitud de a
menos b y con esas tres longitudes voy a
construir un triángulo que ahora ya sé
que siempre voy a poder construir este
triángulo este triángulo siempre lo voy
a poder construir justo por lo que
acabamos de ver y justo por lo que
acabamos de probar este triángulo va a
tener como un lado la longitud debe como
otro lado la longitud de amd y como el
tercer lado la longitud de a menos b y
darte cuenta que este triángulo ya está
en r2 es un triángulo que podemos
dibujar porque acuérdate que las
longitudes son escalares y por lo tanto
yo ya puedo trabajar con este triángulo
ahora para que tanto construir un
triángulo porque los triángulos tienen
ángulos y entonces fíjate bien la forma
en la que voy a definir un an
entre dos vectores y ojo este es el
ángulo que quiero definir va a ser de la
siguiente manera voy a definir un ángulo
entre dos vectores de una manera muy
sencilla lo voy a definir como el ángulo
que se forma en el triángulo cuyos lados
son estos y que además se forma entre el
lado que tiene la longitud de a y el
lado que tiene la longitud debe o
podemos decir el ángulo que es opuesto
al lado que tiene la longitud de a menos
b justo así voy a definir el ángulo
entre dos vectores pero fíjate la
importancia de lo que acabo de decir
imagínate dos vectores en r 100 ya que
los tenemos en el recién es muy fácil
entonces encontrar o pensar en el ángulo
entre dos vectores lo que hay que
fijarme es en el ángulo que se forma
entre estos dos lados en el triángulo
que se forma con la longitud de estos
vectores que buena onda la forma de
definir un ángulo es con un ángulo pero
bueno realmente esto es bastante útil y
nos va a servir bastante en los
siguientes vídeos pero bueno para esto
qué relación tiene todo esto que estamos
viendo bueno voy a relacionar este
ángulo con la famosa ley
- espero que recuerde sus clases de
trigonometría y si no sería bastante
bueno que le eches un ojo a la lista que
tienen que ver con trigonometría de los
vídeos de khan academy y bueno que decía
la ley de ccoo se nos dice que si
tenemos un triángulo cuyos lados son abc
entonces se cuadrada es igual a cuadrada
más b cuadrada menos dos veces a b por
el coche no del ángulo que es opuesto a
ese lado y si te das cuenta es casi un
teorema de pitágoras solamente que su
teorema de pitágoras degenerado porque
el teorema de pitágoras sirve para
triángulos que son rectángulos mientras
que la ley de ccoo se nos sirve para
todos los triángulos y bueno para que
estoy diciendo toda esta ley de cosenos
porque si te das cuenta voy a hacer la
misma analogía de la ley de cosenos con
este triángulo que tengo aquí con este
triángulo de azul me voy a aplicar en
sus lados y en este ángulo que acabo de
definir porque entonces nosotros vamos a
tener la siguiente relación me queda que
este lado el que es opuesto a este
ángulo que quiero definir que por cierto
es la longitud de a menos b va a cumplir
que propiedad bueno la longitud de a
menos b al cuadrado es igual a la
longitud de a elevado al cuadrado lo
único que estoy haciendo es aplicando la
ley de cosa
a este triángulo de azul que me acabo de
encontrar la longitud debe elevada al
cuadrado más la longitud de ha elevado
al cuadrado ya esto le voy a quitar dos
veces a por b es decir la longitud de b
por la longitud de a o la longitud de a
por la longitud de ven es lo mismo menos
dos veces la longitud de up por la
longitud de b por el coseno del ángulo
que se forma entre los lados y b o dicho
de la misma manera por el coseno del
ángulo que es opuesto al lado cuya
longitud es la longitud del vector a
menos b y es que esto ya está perfecto
porque ya tengo una relación de los
lados con este ángulo que acabo de
definir ahora vamos a recordar una
propiedad bastante importante que hemos
visto varias veces si yo tengo la
longitud de un vector elevada al
cuadrado pues es lo mismo que tener este
vector punto ese mismo vector es decir
si yo tengo la longitud de a menos b al
cuadrado pues esto es lo mismo que
tomarnos a menos b punto al menos 20
esto ya lo hemos visto varias veces y
bueno si yo desarrollo el producto punto
que me va a quedar vamos a distribuir el
producto punto entre estos dos binomios
de vectores y entonces que obtengo
apuntó a después nos va a quedar menos
y después a esto yo tengo que quitar
este punto este punto am vamos a notar
lo menos b punto
y por último que nos queda me tengo que
tomar menos por menos más y punto b lo
único que hice fue distribuir este
producto punto porque ahora lo que nos
va a quedar es algo sorprendente fíjate
muy bien yo tengo aquí en primer lugar
apuntó a pues esto es lo mismo que la
longitud de a elevada al cuadrado justo
la misma propiedad y después tengo menos
apuntó ve menos ve punto a pues esto es
exactamente lo mismo que tomarme menos
dos veces apuntó b menos dos veces
apuntó ven y bueno a esto le voy a
agregar punto me pero por la misma
propiedad de punto b es lo mismo que la
longitud de b elevada al cuadrado muy
bien y todo esto para que porque todo
esto es lo mismo que la longitud de a
menos b elevado al cuadrado
todo esto fue aplicar una propiedad de
la longitud de un vector elevada al
cuadrado pero además nos dice que esto
es igual a toda la parte derecha de esta
igualdad es decir esto es igual y voy a
hacer
trampa voy a agarrar todo esto de aquí
lo voy a copiar y después lo voy a pegar
así que vamos a seleccionar todo esto y
esto es para que nos ahorramos tiempo y
pueda yo escribir todo esto de una
manera rapidísima así que seleccionemos
copiar y seleccionemos pegar y perfecto
aquí tengo una igualdad y bueno estoy
haciendo todo esto por una razón porque
si te das cuenta aquí voy a poder
cancelar varios términos del lado
izquierdo está una longitud de a elevada
al cuadrado del lado derecho y también
vámonos estos dos se cancela del lado
izquierdo tengo la longitud de b elevada
al cuadrado del lado derecho también
vámonos y después simple sencillamente
me va a quedar que menos 2 y fíjate aquí
tengo menos 2 y los menos 2 a ver si
también lo puedo cancelar este y éste se
van porque son la misma operación
voy a tener menos 2 multiplicando del
lado izquierdo y menos 2 multiplicando
del lado derecho se cancelan también y
simple y sencillamente me voy a quedar
con apuntó b es decir me estoy tomando
el producto punto de dos vectores a
punto b esto va a ser igual a quién y
fíjate la importancia de lo que estoy
diciendo me estoy tomando la longitud
de dos vectores por otra parte me estoy
tomando al ángulo entre estos dos
vectores y además me estoy tomando el
producto punto entre estos dos vectores
y entonces voy a obtener que a punto b
es exactamente igual que la longitud de
a por la longitud de b por el coseno del
ángulo que se forma entre estos dos
vectores recuerda como acabamos de
definir un ángulo con un ángulo este
ángulo de aquí es el ángulo que habíamos
definido como el ángulo entre dos
vectores es decir recuerda que el ángulo
que se forma entre los lados que tienen
a la longitud de ahí a la longitud de
ven es el ángulo que está entre estos
dos vectores el ángulo que se forma
entre estos dos vectores entre ellos y
aquí está tenemos ya una relación que
tiene que ver con el producto punto de
dos vectores y con la longitud de estos
dos vectores y el coseno del ángulo que
se forma entre estos dos vectores y
entonces si yo tengo dos vectores pues
yo puedo calcular ya su longitud
podemos tener calcular de una manera
explícita su producto punto y entonces
ya puedo saber qué ángulo tienen estos
dos vectores y ya no importa si los
vectores estén
multidimensional puedes dar en el recién
esto también es válido pero bueno esta
definición no se acaba aquí también si
yo tengo que es igual hace veces ven y
ojo estoy tomando me hace positiva
entonces quiere decir que el ángulo
entre ellos es igual a cero me estoy
tomando dos vectores que son con
lineales
si van a la misma dirección entonces por
definición el ángulo es igual a cero y
si estos dos vectores son con lineales
pero van en sentido contrario es decir
se es negativa entonces por definición
el ángulo que se forma entre ellos es de
180 grados en el primer caso tengo dos
vectores que van a la misma dirección
pero son vectores co lineales y bueno si
te das cuenta aquí el ángulo que se
forma entre ellos dos por 60 grados no
hay ningún ángulo entre estos dos
vectores y en el segundo caso me estoy
tomando dos vectores que son co lineales
pero que van en la dirección contraria
es decir que éste es negativo y pues
claramente el ángulo que se forma entre
ellos es de 180 grados y esto tiene toda
la lógica del mundo porque si nosotros
nos regresamos a nuestra idea del
triángulo que se forma con estos
vectores pues nos vamos a dar cuenta que
dos sectores que son con lineales no
forman ningún triángulo forman una línea
pero un triángulo no lo forman y bueno
además de todo esto esto nos da pie a
pensar en un concepto muy importante en
lo que se definen como dos vectores
perpendiculares o dos vectores
ortogonales y esto nos va a servir
bastante en los siguientes vídeos
yo voy a definir perpendicularidad entre
dos vectores a ver déjame ponerlo aquí
definición sean dos vectores
perpendiculares perpendiculares esto
quiere decir que el ángulo que se forma
entre ellos es de 90 grados y ojo me
estoy diciendo que el ángulo que se
forma entre ellos es de 90 grados porque
nosotros ya podemos calcular con estos
dos vectores el vector ay y el vector de
su producto punto la longitud de estos
dos vectores y entonces si el ángulo que
me sale entre estos dos vectores es de
90 grados voy a decir que estos dos
vectores son ortogonales o son vectores
perpendiculares y bueno para
encontrarnos este ángulo de 90 grados lo
único que habría que hacer es sustituir
en esta fórmula que tenemos aquí o claro
claro y eso también es muy importante
porque esto me da pie a pensar que es
necesario
de dos vectores que no sean el vector
nulo o el vector cero porque imagínate
si tuviéramos el vector cero nos
meteríamos en un grave problema nosotros
tendríamos por una parte nos tendremos
que tomar el producto punto de un vector
con el vector cero el producto punto de
un vector con el vector cero pues me da
cero y por otra parte tengo la longitud
del vector cero que es cero por lo que
sea lo cual me da cero y entonces me
quedaría algo de la forma cero es igual
a cero por el coseno del ángulo que se
forma entre ellos dos y si desde aquí
quiero despejar el ángulo que se forma
entre ellos dos me va a quedar que el
coseno de este ángulo es decir el coseno
del ángulo teta es igual a cero entre
cero lo cual es indefinido es decir si
yo pienso en un vector que es igual al
vector nulo entonces me voy a meter en
un problema de que no tengo nada
definido es por eso que es necesario que
el vector y el vector b sean vectores
distintos de cero pero bueno regresemos
a la idea de perpendicular dos vectores
distintos de cero son perpendiculares si
el ángulo entre ellos es de 90 grados a
veces vamos a pensar eso porque esto nos
va a dar pie algo muy importante fíjate
bien me voy a tomar dos vectores que
sean perpendiculares
es decir el ángulo entre ellos es de 90
grados por lo tanto qué va a pasar
déjame escribirlo por acá me voy a tomar
de esta misma fórmula la idea de que el
ángulo de 90 grados por lo tanto tengo
dos vectores perpendiculares y entonces
me va a quedar que a punto b es lo mismo
que la longitud de an por la longitud de
bem por el coseno del ángulo que se
forma entre ellos dos pero el ángulo que
se forme entre ellos dos es 90 grados y
cuánto vale el cociente de 90 grados
pues el corte nuevamente a grados es 0
si haces memoria con tu círculo
trigonométrico o con la gráfica del
coseno base recordar que el concepto de
90 grados es igual a cero
entonces me va a quedar que a punto ave
es igual a cero porque 0 por lo que sea
es 0 y esto nos da pie algo
importantísimo fíjate bien me tumbé dos
vectores perpendiculares y acabamos de
obtener que dos vectores perpendiculares
me dan el producto punto igual a cero
abel perpendiculares implican que a
punto b es igual a cero y esto es
bastante importante pero ten mucho
cuidado porque el regreso no se cumple
esto no es un sí y sólo sí porque si yo
me tomo dos vectores que su producto
punto sea igual a cero
que no sean perpendiculares y el caso
más sencillo es pensar en el vector 0
fíjate bien si yo me tomo el vector 0.4
otro vector pues esto es igual a 0 justo
por cómo está definido el producto punto
y que dijimos del vector 0 que el vector
0 no está definido en toda esta teoría
que acabamos de crear cuando nosotros
pensamos en el vector 0 no hay ningún
ángulo entre ellos por lo tanto no puedo
ver o no puedo pensar en un ángulo de 90
grados entre estos dos vectores entonces
hay que tener mucho cuidado si tengo dos
vectores perpendiculares esto implica
que a bs igual a cero a punto b igual a
cero no implica forzosamente que sean
dos vectores perpendiculares pero ojo y
esto es muy importante si los vectores
son vectores distintos de cero entonces
si se cumple el sí sólo si hay b
distintos de cero cumplen que son
perpendiculares si a punto es igual a
cero y se apuntó veces igual a cero y
los vectores son distintos de cero
entonces hay veces son perpendiculares
esto es un si y sólo si cuando hablamos
de vectores distintos de cero y bueno
vamos a seguir con todo esto si yo
pienso en a punto b igual a cero a punto
b igual a cero
esto me va a implicar una cosa muy
importante lo que podemos decir y lo
podemos decir por definición el producto
punto de dos vectores igual a cero me
dice que estos dos vectores son
ortogonales son ortogonales y el
producto punto de estos dos es igual a
cero y muchos llaman perpendicular a
ortogonal pero no forzosamente es lo
mismo porque hay un caso muy importante
que estaríamos olvidando el caso donde
el vector uno de ellos sea el vector
cero dos vectores son ortogonales si su
producto punto es igual a cero
esto puede ser o que sean
perpendiculares si son distintos de cero
o que uno de ellos el vector cero y por
lo tanto el vector cero es ortogonal a
cualquier vector que esté en nuestro
espacio de dimensiones inclusive a él
mismo el welter ser súper gracioso
porque es ortogonal hasta el mismo ojo
aquí es muy importante no confundir
estos dos conceptos son muy parecidos
pero hay una gran diferencia entre ellos
dos vectores son perpendiculares si su
producto punto es igual a cero pero
recuerda que no podemos hablar de
perpendicularidad con el vector cero
porque no está definido el ángulo
de dos vectores cuando uno de ellos es
el vector cero así que por primera vez
en su carrera matemática podemos ver la
importancia de usar bien las
definiciones porque en geometría o en
trigonometría perpendicular y ortogonal
es lo mismo son sinónimos pero en el
lenguaje de álgebra lineal aquí es
importante mencionar las distinciones
entre estas dos palabras porque ahora
estamos usando matemáticas de las
grandes ligas y es muy importante tener
cuidado con las palabras que usamos y
muy precisos con nuestras definiciones
porque si no lo hacemos así podemos
construir un bonche de matemáticas hacer
demostraciones importantes crear
teoremas grandes y que todo se caiga por
no ser precisos en nuestras definiciones
bueno así que ya puedes ir corriendo con
tu profesor de matemáticas y decirle que
ya sabes la diferencia entre ortogonal y
perpendicular y además de paso puedes
presumir de que ya sabes cómo se define
el ángulo entre dos vectores pero bueno
de cualquier manera aquí está la
definición del ángulo entre dos vectores
y espero que te sea bastante útil